stratford-on-avon district council is
currently consulting on a site
allocations plan and we want to hear
your views
to help explain what it's all about this
short video explains part of the plan
that relates to reserve housing sites
essentially what they are why we need
them as well as how we've identified
them
our existing plan the core strategy is
delivering the homes that this district
needs
however there's always the risk that
some of the sites already identified
do not actually get built or that
additional needs for housing arise
for this reason the site allocations
plan proposes reserve housing sites that
the council will release for development
if necessary
there there is a safety net if required
chapter 2 and policies sap 1 to sap 5
relate to reserve
sites there are 4 reasons why we are
identifying reserve
sites the first is to help us maintain a
5-year supply of housing
as we are required to do by the
government our latest figures show that
we have the equivalent of seven years
worth of supply
which is really good news the second
reason
relates to additional jobs being created
by jaguar land rover at gaiden lighthorn
heath
these new workers will need homes to
live in
the third and fourth reason relates to
additional housing needs arising outside
of the district
for example in birmingham or coventry we
have to do our bit to meet any such
shortfalls because we're in the same
housing market area
so have we identified the proposed
reserve sites
firstly we have applied the approach
already established in the core strategy
which identifies stratford-upon-avon as
the main town
eight main rural centres including
ulster bidford and southam
and four categories of local service
villages
secondly we have assessed the sites
against a range of technical criteria
including flood risk highways and
heritage
all this technical information is
available on the website at
www.stratford.gov
dot uk forward slash sappo
we have not identified reserve housing
sites in the greenvale or in the
cotswold aomb
all of the sites proposed will have
impacts and none are completely free
from constraints but we think on balance
the sites proposed are potentially
suitable
this is why we're consulting to hear
your views
are also proposing that developers of
reserve sites meet much more stringent
low-carbon requirements to help
combat climate change the proposed
reserve housing sites are listed in
annex 1 of the preferred options version
of the site allocations plan
and are also shown on the maps in part a
of chapter eight
more detailed site performers
identifying how site-specific
constraints should be overcome
are included in annex 2. i hope that's
helped and that you're now a little more
clued in as to why we need reserve sites
and how we've identified them
remember to find out more and to have
your say go to www.stratford.gov
dot uk forward slash sapo